hello everyone my name is corey padilla
and
i'm here from dovetail genomics to talk
about some
exciting work that we've been doing in
the field of structural variation
and so what i'm going to talk to you
about today is being able to capture
s and bs and large structural variants
in terms of inter-chromosomal
translocation events
using a 3-d ngs approach
to genomics
and so just to set the stage here um one
of the things that we do know about
short read whole genome sequencing
approaches is
they generally have a hard time in
characterizing large structural
variation
so this is largely in part because
they're limited
in the long range interactions that they
are able to capture
they often require high read support to
be able to
correctly call breakpoints and there is
very low consensus
across different uh tools to call these
structural variation events
and here we're just showing you the
different types of large structural
variation
that can be contained in genomes and
that people are
interested in characterizing so
our solution to this approach or to
be able to characterize large structural
variation
is uh this process called high c
and it's really based uh along this
technology called proximity ligation
and so just to walk you through the
molecular biology
uh at the bottom here starting on the
left we link
dna inside the cell so we
capture that 3d orientation of the
genome
and then once that genome is kind of
frozen in place
we fragment it historically that's been
done with restriction enzymes
we have used different approaches here
at dovetail to
make that a much better approach and
we'll talk about that here in a second
then once that genome is fragmented we
tell it to ligate
back to itself but instead of ligating
back in a linear fashion it ligates back
in terms of what's closest to it in 3d
space
and so what you get after that ligation
and then removing the
the crosslinks is chimeric dna
that's reflective of uh 3d
proximal dna rather than linear
information
and then once that chimeric dna is
cleaned up you just turn it into a
sequence library where you pull down on
biotin enriching particularly for those
ligation
sites now i mentioned in the
previous slide that historically
fragmenting
the the genome has been done with
restriction enzymes and this
generates quite a bit of problems when
it comes to
including all the genome so what i'm
showing here
are genomic coverage profiles uh
on the left and then on the right are
the read pile up
in the integrative genome viewer and
each one of the
rows is a different approach to hi-c
in terms of fragmenting the genome so
you could use a single restriction
enzyme
you could use multiple restriction
enzymes or what we do here at dovetail
is use a sequence independent
endonuclease
to fragment and the dotted line in each
one of those coverage profiles is
shotgun so here we're looking at how
many bases
exhibit 20x or 40x coverage um
so the coverage is on the x-axis number
of basis is on the y-axis
and so if you look at the restriction
enzyme approaches they
are there's a large number of bases that
exhibit low
to no coverage and on the flip side of
that there are quite a number of bases
that get over
sequence that makes sense because if
you're cutting and enriching the data
restriction enzyme sites you're going to
be over sequencing those
and what that that's left with is a
bunch of
gaps in your genomic coverage so on the
right
the restriction enzyme approaches
there's clearly large gaps in
coverage and at the very bottom row with
the obviously we are able to
recapitulate
shotgun light coverage and that's
reflected in the reed pile up showing
nice
uniform signal there so we can actually
capture the snips and that'll come into
play later
in the talk so what this sort of
increase in uh coverage profile plus
that long range 3d information allows us
to do
is expand the ability for
short reads to act as long read
information
so you can now do large structural
variation detection
you could do your indel genotyping you
can do haplotype
phasing you can then assemble and
scaffold your genomes based on those 3d
contacts
and then you can also dial into the
chromosome
conformation which is really the key
driver or one of the key drivers
in how genes are being transcribed so
bringing
regulatory elements that are uh
you know up to megabase away megabases
away from
the gene of interest together uh
mediated by ctcf and cohesion to turn
that gene on
um and so really what we're going to do
today is focus on
the structural variation detection and
then we'll end
with the snip and indel genotyping
capabilities and what that means
for building phased
diploid assemblies
and so one of the things that we want to
start with is orientating you
on how to read these data so
here uh is a sort of pictograph of how
you would visualize
these hi-c data so each one
of these points on the graph is a read
pair
with the x-axis being the position on
the genome and the y-axis being
the the insert size that's captured in
those read pairs
and so for each one of these dots you
can see two lines kind of running
away from it as a triangle representing
a region where
read one maps to and a region where
uh read two maps to some distance away
and that distance is informative
of how the genome is folded in on itself
so what this really looks like is
this is a picture of two chromosomes in
a genome and we're looking at the
contacts between
uh within chromosomes and across
chromosomes and as you can see
so if you look at chromosome a there's a
lot more contacts within chromosome
than there are uh contacts across
chromosome a to chromosome b
uh and the other thing is too is that
you can see there's
a scale there where there's a lot of
black pixels and then there's some red
pixels kind of close to the
uh x axes that just indicates there is
more contacts in the shorter range than
there are in the longer range
just indicating that regions that are
kind of close to each other in linear
space have a higher frequency of contact
than regions that don't interact and so
one of the things to point out here
is that there is very little trans noise
or
inter-chromosomal interactions as you
can see with the big
gap there in between chromosome a and
chromosome b
and that gap is a place that we look in
our contact matrixes
to call trans chromosomal uh sorry
interchromosomal translocation events
another way to view these contact
matrixes is
through a pairwise perpendicular matrix
where
you start with that sort of triangle
picture which is
um really only the chromosome a and b
on the x-axis with the insert size on
the y-axis like i showed in the previous
figure
the other way to think about it would be
to make a mirror image of this
to be a pairwise matrix where chromosome
a
and b are on the x-axis and
the y-axis so you can actually just ask
the question
um how many contacts do i have between
any given region in chromosome a with
another given region in chromosome
a or how many uh how many interactions
are there
between chromosome and chromosome b so
these are both basically depicting the
same type
of information one is just pairwise
giving you that sort of square view and
one is just using a single reference
genome
for the triangle view that you see on
the left
and so as i was pointing out earlier
that sort of blank space
in the middle is where we look to
classify and detect structural variation
so what we're showing here are different
contact matrixes
occur within the well-characterized cell
line hcc 1187
and the top row is the
control bl cell line that doesn't have
structural variation in it
and below that we're showing the contact
matrix for the htc 1187 line which
has known uh variation and so what we're
pointing at here
in every single one of these arrows is
the actual inversion
deletion or translocation event and then
at the very bottom window
we're zooming in on that structural
variation
so you can see exactly where the
breakpoint is and how far that
breakpoint
or how far that variation expands
between the two chromosomes
or even within a chromosome and then you
can start asking questions about
the genes that are associated with these
breakpoints
and so uh for the next part of the
presentation we're really going to be
focusing
in on the inter-chromosomal
translocation events
kind of what we're showing here on the
far right
column where we see a translocation
event uh
between chromosome 10 and chromosome 13
in hcc 1187 and next we're going to show
you how exactly do
we identify and capture these variation
effects
so to start with um what we've been
really working on in our r
d team is to develop a algorithm to be
able to
uh catch these structural variation
events
so uh it starts by looking just at the
number of
chromosome pairs so asking between
chromosome 1 and chromosome 2
are there any contacts that are higher
frequency than expected by sort of the
basal background level of contacts in
between chromosomes
once we have that information and
identified the regions that have higher
contact
we then filter out the the contacts
that are generated by the background
noise from there
we normalize that contact matrix to be
an observed over
expected ratio and then from there we
use
image processing to look at where
those contacts are actually occurring
across the chromosomes
and just to kind of walk you through an
example of this
we're looking again at hcc 1187 and
we're
going to characterize a chromosome
a translocation event between chromosome
2 and 20
where we're plotting here on the x-axis
the position on chromosome 2
and on the y-axis is the contact score
between
all other chromosomes and so instead of
plotting or
having a legend for every single color
for every chromosome we're just calling
out here the
important uh contacts so we have
chromosome 19 and chromosome
20 that exhibit contacts that are over
the expected rate which is that dotted
uh
line the horizontal line and so
then we can ask the question okay of
chromosome
20 what does the contact matrix
look like from there and so after we
filter out
the sort of noise contacts in the
background that are below that expected
rate
we get an image that looks like this
where we see an
increased number of contacts between
chromosome 2
which is on the x-axis on the top and
chromosome 20 which is
on the y-axis and as you can see there
is this really bright spot
between the chromosome this particular
region of chromosome 2 and chromosome
20.
now if we remove what's uh
after we normalize the contact matrix
for what's observed
versus expected we get a clearer view of
sort of the hot spot there
um of the contacts between the two
chromosomes
and then from there we make it binary so
we can say that the white region
is the region that is of higher contacts
the darker regions are
sort of background noise that we don't
expect to play a role in
the chromosomal translocation event and
then from there we use image processing
to then say
where the actual breakpoints exist based
on the contact matrix so here
we're looking at the regions of
chromosome 2 in the
first three columns there and then the
regions of chromosome 20
that that interacts with chromosome 2
and then what the
minimum score is uh that 1.83 which is
the
sort of expected rate of contact between
those two
and we're basically saying that this
contact region that these break points
exhibit a contact frequency that's
higher than the expected rate
uh which is again what we see when we
just look at the
number of pairs that are exhibit a
higher level of contacts and
the sort of score score figure
and so what we've done is we've tried
this with a number of different
cell lines at a number of different
sequencing depths here so
we're looking at different cell lines
between breast cancer with hcc 1187
and melanoma in colo h29
and then we also have some negative
controls with the htc 1187
bl line the gm 12878 cell line and then
the bl cell line for
uh the colo as well and so even at
different coverages what we're able to
do
is capture all of the true positives
that that exist in these cell lines and
we have
very a very low false positive rate and
those asterisks in the false positive
column indicates contacts that
actually are supported so these are
translocation events that are supported
by our contact matrixes that have
yet to be actually characterized in
these cell lines
and in a bit we'll show you exactly uh
what those
sort of false positives that we think
are true positives look like
and then um we're we're basically
capturing very few false negatives uh
with our data type
as well so this works across a range of
sample types
er their cancer types and as well as a
range of
sequence depth and
to really sort of call out here the
sensitivity of this assay at
low sequencing depth we've taken the the
same cell line htc 1187
and we've down sampled uh from 46x to
6x to 3x coverage and have asked are we
still
capturing the same true positive signal
and
are we still um not calling any false
negatives and so what we're showing here
in the uh the image on the right
and the left column we're showing the
position on chromosome
position on chromosome 14 for the x-axis
and again that contact score on the
y-axis
and as you can see as we move down
between
46x which is the top row between 6x and
3x
which are the bottom two rows in
coverage that same
signal the same pattern of increased
contacts between chromosome 14
and chromosome 20 is easily observed and
is very much
above our signal to noise ratio there
so indicating that we are truly calling
these
uh translocation events even as we move
all the way down into 3x
coverage which is really really really
low coverage
and then for the the false negative
which is a known translocation event
between
uh chromosome five and two we can see
that as we
kind of down sample we lose the
uh we maintain the contacts between 46
x and 6x coverage and then that signal
kind of goes away
at 3x so we're we're
fairly positive here that we are
we maintain a high degree of sensitivity
even as we move all the way down into 3x
coverage now for the
those translocation events that uh are
false positives that haven't yet been
characterized but we actually
have contact matrix support for them is
uh this one particular one in hcc 1187
which is between chromosome 4 and
chromosome 8
so on these contact matrixes the one on
the left
is from the control line which is the
htc 1187bl
and we're plotting the contacts between
chromosome 4 and chromosome 8
on the y-axis and then the one next to
that is the
hcc 1187 cancerous line
and as you can see in the control line
there is really no
bright spot here in the contact matrix
it all kind of looks like background
noise
but when we look at the hcc 1187 line on
the
right we see this really bright spot
that pops out
uh at us that basically indicates that
the very sort of start of chromosome 4
is interacting with a region of
chromosome 8 between
about 15 megabases to about 45 megabases
uh along the uh along chromosome 8.
so we we do have very kind of strong
evidence here that this
is a true structural variation that has
yet to be characterized in the cell line
and our next steps here are to go in and
pcr this out and just confirm that it
is in fact a a true signal
so uh i'm bringing this sort of coverage
image back up
here because we're about to dial in into
the
the snip abilities of this data type as
well
so previous versions of this high cn
product
single nucleotide variants and that has
again there are gaps in coverage and our
omni-c as you can see again
at the bottom we're recapitulating
shotgun like coverage
meaning that we should be able to call
snips
and single nucleotide variations at a
rate that is similar to that of shotgun
data
and so we've done that here with the
cell line gm12878 so we're looking at
the table on the left which are snips
that were identified in the cell line
gm12878 using gatk
and we have true positive false negative
and then sensitivity and precision for
each for the columns and then the
rows are shotgun data the obviously data
and then restriction enzyme based hi-c
data
and basically the key thing that we want
to point out here is that the
sensitivity and precision
of obviously in being able to detect
snips
is very close to that of shotgun data
which is what we expect based on the
coverage
and it far outstrips the
restriction enzyme-based hi-c data
now the table on the right is asking can
we
successfully phase the haplotypes in
gm12878
uh with the snips that have been
identified through
the omnic data set and comparing that
again to shotgun data and high c data
and so basically the punch line here is
that omni-c data that our
sort of sequence independent uh approach
to fragmenting the genome
is able to capture more heterozygous
sniffs
than single or research and enzyme-based
high-seed which is what we expect based
on the coverage
and we have a much lower switch error
rate than what we see with
again other high c approaches it's not
as good as shotgun but it is
much better than other high c approaches
but one of the things that we like to
point out here
is that you can phase chromosomes end to
end
with the proximity ligation data which
is something that you can't do with
shotgun data because your insert size
with shotgun data is about 1kb
at best with the proximity ligation
approach
your insert size is basically the range
of the chromosome
and so if you have read one that you
know contains a lot of heterozygous
snips that maps to one part of the
genome
you can take read two that might be
megabases away and know that that
particular read is a part of that same
haplotype because it's linked over a
long range of distance so
you can pretty much phase across the
centromere
which again is something that shotgun
data can't do
um and then restriction enzyme-based ic
data just can't really quite get the
same
switch error rate because it's too gappy
there's too
many regions with low coverage
and so one of the the cooler things that
you can do with
with this information is if you have pac
bio data
long rate data and you have this
proximity ligation on the c data
you can pre-phase your long-range reads
into two buckets and build haplotype
assemblies from scratch and which is
what we've done here
with gm 12878 where we've taken again
the pac bio data
aligned our omni series to them and then
have created two haplotype buckets
of pac bio reads and then have generated
and scaffold uh assemblies for each
habla type de novo
and here we're just looking at sort of
the
genomic uh assembly stats here what's
the total size between the haplotypes
the n50 the n90 and the max scaffold
size uh realistically showing
you that we are capturing the full
genome uh in each one of these
haplotypes
and then below we're showing the late
density plot which is basically saying
what is the linkage between each one of
these read pairs
and you can see that uh these
sort of hot spots that are going along
the diagonal are basically the length of
a chromosome and so we're just we're
re-capitulating
the the two haplotype assemblies from
scratch here
so if you have a genome that's maybe
exhibiting a high degree of variation
like say it has chromothrypsis
you can use this approach to probably
build out
a uh a new assembly from scratch
of that very broken and fragmented
genome
so instead of comparing it to a
reference genome you can build your own
that's informative around those
structural variation events
and just sort of as a proof of principle
here
we've looked at how this phasing works
between gm12878 and the hg002 genome
and basically what you're looking at
here are k-mers that are coming from
the mom on the y-axis versus k-mers that
are coming from the
paternal line on the x-axis and you can
basically see that
we're we're very much able to separate
out these k-mers
into their specific haplotypes so again
kind of recapitulating the
the idea that we can successfully build
uh
uh deployed assembly from scratch
so leveraging that uh the snip ability
along with that long range information
where
we're really able to build these diploid
assemblies
and one of the last things that we
really want to point out here
is that you can hit this date
this data type with a hybrid capture
panel historically because uh
hi-c data use restriction enzymes you
had to
really redesign your probe set to
incorporate a restriction site
because we don't rely on those you can
take off the
the shelf products here like extra
lockdown
and truesight or really any other um
hybrid capture panel and apply it to the
data and so on the left here what i'm
showing is a workflow of how you'd go
from your sample to your
to your hybrid capture approach and then
how you would process that data
and on the right we're showing the
different types of
uh products that we know we're
compatible with
and then on the bottom we're showing a
one of those contact matrixes that are
reflective of topology
and then we're on the bottom we're
showing
data that has been enriched for rpl5
using the extra lockdown series
and i've been able to not only enrich
the data for that one specific gene with
the rpl5 but we're now
able to ask the question what other
genomic regions
does rpl5 have significant interactions
with
which are depicted there by that arc so
if you kind of already know
that you have a gene of interest um you
can now
start asking the question what is this
gene interacting with
and are there snips upstream or
downstream of this gene
or even within that gene that impact the
connectivity between the rest of the
chromosome or
if there's a translocation event if it
interacts more frequently with a
chromosome
that's not where it lives so
i just wanted to kind of point that out
that uh you can really sort of dial in
this approach to maybe not be
genome-wide but to be more gene-centric
and so we'd like to end with pointing
out that this data type this
omni-c data type is really sort of a
very flexible data type that allows you
to interrogate
everything from large structural
variants all the way down to single
nucleotide polymorphisms
and as well as gives you the ability to
ask questions about the 3d architecture
of your genome as well
and so with that i'd like to say thank
you and field any questions